how much does the atmosphere weigh the
atmospheric pressure you feel at the
Earth's surface comes from the weight of
all the air above you right the way up
to the edge of space specifically the
force per square meter or pressure on
the surface is given by the mass of
atmosphere in the 1 square meter
cylinder of air above multiplied by the
Earth's gravitational acceleration so if
we divide the pressure by the
gravitational acceleration we find out
the mass of air above every square meter
on the planet average atmospheric
pressure is about 1,000 MB or 100,000
pascals and because the gravitational
acceleration at the surface is about 10
m/s squared that means there's about
10,000 kg of air floating above you and
above every other square meter of the
Earth's surface right now to find out
the approximate mass of the entire
atmosphere then we just multiply this
number by the surface area of Earth and
get an answer of about 5 million billion
tons which for reference is about 1
millionth of the total mass of the Earth